yeah good morning we're outside clark
high school where it's still an early
start traffic here we're not seeing very
many cars we have seen some students
make their way inside as you can see
right now some staff members walking
into the school so ccsd is really
stressing this parents should not bring
their kids to school if they are clothed
positive or they're feeling symptoms so
what is the protocol
parent should follow to notify the
district the clark county school
district says if the positive covet test
or exposure happened within the last
five days parents can start by calling
the health services department the
district's covet 19 hotline should be on
your screen
however that phone line is only open
during regular business hours this
morning parents again are talking with
their children about mask wearing and
safety
i'm glad the kids are going back to
school so they get educated to get their
knowledge that they need to to have but
i don't think there's not that big of a
problem as long as the teachers keep it
strict when it comes to that policy
because of the five-day pause students
will have class on february the 7th and
april 25th those days were originally
scheduled as days off in the school
calendar and going back to the cover 19
hotline the district's website does note
that they have been experiencing a high
volume of phone calls there's an option
for parents to fill out a form online
however that form is only open also
during business hours reporting live
hector mejia live local now